Nami betrayed Luffy Sanji abandoned him
and beat him up and Robin framed Luffy
for assassination however in all of
these circumstances Luffy instantly
forgave his crewmate because of his kind
heart and belief in their true nature
now can you imagine what any other
pirate would have done in these
situations what would the main
antagonist or the ruthless Captain kits
in other words what would have happened
if instead of being kind-hearted and
loving Luffy was power hungry and I was
starting with chapter one when Luffy is
first inspired to become a great pirate
by Shanks now this part of the story
remains mostly the same except for one
key difference Luffy is still captured
by Bandits Shanks still rescues Luffy
and loses his arm and the iconic Straw
Hat still gets passed down to Luffy
however the small but massively
impactful difference comes when Shanks
tells Luffy that he cannot join his crew
as you might remember in the original
Shanks tells Luffy that he is too young
to join the crew but for the purpose of
this video Let's assume that Shanks is
going to tell Luffy that he is not
strong enough to join the red hair
Pirates and as you will see this
apparently Small Change is Going to make
Luffy believe that he can only become a
great pirate by becoming the most
powerful one and while to a certain
degree Luffy does believe that for this
video Luffy is taking this idea to an
extreme level and he also learned from
Lucky Rue that in this world you must
kill or be killed and you won't believe
how this tiny little change is going to
affect the battle at Marine Fort later
on in the story but for now shank still
leaves Don Island and Luffy spends 10
years training before setting out to
gather his pirate crew and unlike some
of the other water videos that we've
done on this channel such as what if
Luffy had an admiral's devil fruit or
what if Luffy joined shanks's crew we're
going to this time spend significant
time focusing on the East blue
specifically because the Dynamics of the
strawhead crew in this scenario are
going to massively change the Luffy sets
out eager to gather a strong crew and
fight anyone in his path he still loves
to have fun at party he still wants to
become pirate king and he still has a
way of convincing people to follow him
he's still very charismatic however now
he is a very power hungry Pirates as a
result he is significantly more
cold-hearted and he has less emotional
intelligence plus he is willing to kill
and he only wants crewmates who are
strong or very useful to his crew now
the first person at Luffy meets is this
pink-haired kid Kobe Luffy mocks the
enslaved deck swab for being such a
weakling and he still clobbers alvida
and sets him free but instead of
becoming Luffy's friends this wannabe
Marine now vows to one day take Luffy
down himself next up we have Shell
Island and here Luffy would easily
defeat the corrupt Marine Captain Morgan
and he would probably laugh at seeing
Zorro all tied up however Luffy would
probably still release Zorro after
learning that he is a famous bounty
hunter and then challenges him to a duel
and even though swords are Luffy's main
weakness he would probably still defeat
Zorro somehow because the swordsman is
pretty weak from not eating for so long
however Luffy is quite impressed by
zoro's strength and instead of Killing
Him Luffy does invite Zorro to join his
crew which Zorro of course except
because growing stronger is
coincidentally also his goal now the
pair then travels to Orange town where
the story essentially plays out mostly
the same way Luffy defeats buggy and he
lets Nami come along because she's a
badass Navigator something that the crew
desperately needs and Nami would want to
join because she can steal Luffy's
treasure later on and speaking of
treasure this version of Luffy would
take most of the treasure from buggy
instead of just leaving it for the
ruined Town most likely and so even with
the changes to Luffy we still have our
first two crewmates and they would
likely seek out other Pirates to fight
and pillage before landing at usob's
Hometown as well syrup Village and this
is where we have our first major change
in the story because after defeating the
fake Butler Kudo Luffy never invites
Usopp to join the crew because of his
weak fighting capability so sorry usop
fans our sniper stays observed Village
but at least in this version he gets the
girl and no USA means no Mary either so
Luffy and the crew will need to steal a
different ship somewhere along the way
however next up is the baratier where
the story takes a dream dramatic turn
for the worse the crew would still
defeat it this guy no problem but things
get really interesting when the world's
strongest swordsman mihawk shows up
again for the first time because a
battle-hungry Luffy would never let
Zorro have all the fun fighting such a
strong opponent and there are a lot of
ways that this battle could go but none
of them are too good for the straw hats
because we already saw Zoro almost die
from the original encounter and it could
be even worse for Luffy because of his
weakness to swords in fact it is quite
likely that he could lose an arm or leg
in this fight but let's just assume that
lucky and he similarly gets a massive
injury across his chest like Zorro which
would mean that the crew must now stay
at baratier to heal and during this time
Luffy convinces Sanji to pursue his
dream of finding the all blue so the
cook once again joins the crew here as
well however this prolonged recovery
leaves Nami with the perfect chance to
betray Luffy she steals the treasure and
the ship and she returns to her home
Island where she hopes to pay for The
Village's Freedom now this time this
really leaves Luffy pissed off by not
only his defeat to mihawk but also that
his crewmate would betray him just like
that and so we still head to Ireland
Park where the enraged Luffy storms in
defeats the Fishman arlong who is
terrorizing nami's Village and Luffy is
so Furious that Nami betrayed him that
he could even threaten to destroy her
Village itself but let's just assume
that he eventually allows her to rejoin
because he respects what she's doing to
protect sector people and she really is
very useful to the crew certainly that
takes a different type of strength
however now nami's and Luffy's
relationship is a lot shallower than it
was in the original story so while Luffy
is technically still saving islands and
people from other bad pirates he is not
gaining nearly as many friends and
allies because he is fighting for quite
selfish reasons and keep watching to see
how this will become the Fatal flaw of
Luffy later on however at this point
we've got the whole crew minus usop as
they reach loketown and the last Island
before the grand line here Luffy is of
course never captured by buggy because a
buggy is uh no longer alive thanks but
Luffy is still helpless to fight the
Marine Captain smoker who ate the smoke
logia devil fruit Luffy is still saved
by his father Dragon but the defeat does
leave Luffy desperate to learn how to
fight lokia fruit users so instead of a
party as the crew and just a grand line
and angry Luffy is just determined to
grow much stronger and now the first
person that they meet in the grand line
is the former pirate King's doctor
crocus and of course being a former
Roger pirate means that he would surely
know the basics at least of hockey so
with the defeat to Smoker still on his
mind Luffy convinces crocus to teach him
how to defeat logia food users and this
would require quite some time but
eventually the crew would learn the
basics of armaments and observation
hockey and damn it's going to make quite
a difference to every single fight ahead
in the story now Vivi the prince of
alabasta might still tag along with the
hope that Luffy could somehow save her
kingdom she could even tempt Luffy with
the promise of a strong opponent to
fight on her home Island however when
the crew arrives on drum Island I don't
think they could convince Chopper this
time to join them simply because Luffy
would care more about his monstrous
Powers instead of his capability as a
doctor so no Chopper but they do recruit
some random Joe doctor to join their
crew because they really need one and so
next with no Chopper but this random Joe
they travel to Alabaster where Luffy is
itching to fight another warlord of the
sea after his disastrous defeat by
mihawk and now that Luffy knows the
basics of hockey his fight with
crocodile goes a lot smoother he can
actually punch the San logia fruit user
and eventually manages to defeat him and
so with crocodile down we now reach
another incredibly interesting
Crossroads while I think that Robin
would definitely join the straw hats
once again she would also probably
consider the straw hats to be just
another group of bad guys that she could
stay with to progress her very own plans
but the more interesting question would
probably be what happens with crocodile
you see we have many examples of other
strong Pirates recruiting defeated
Pirates to their crew for example the
emperor of the cicaido tried to recruit
feet after defeating the strawhead
captain eduano at their first encounter
so while it is possible that crocodile
could just be arrested by the Marines
again this version of Luffy invites him
to join the crew because he is a
powerful fighter and crocodile accepts
so with two new crew members from
Alabaster we do continue to Jaya and the
Fateful meeting with the darkness fruit
lohia user blackbeards after Luffy makes
an example out of this springy pirate he
would certainly challenge blackby to a
fight as well and Blackbeard would
welcome this because he is already gonna
try to capture Luffy and turn him into
the world governments and with Luffy's
warped personality these two would
actually probably become quite similar
they're both hungry for power they both
believe in their dreams and they are
willing to do whatever it takes to
achieve those dreams and most
importantly they are both subscribed to
this channel but would you believe me if
I told you that the similarity between
them will lead them to joining forces
later on I mean keep watching and find
out why but for now we will assume that
their fight essentially ends in some
sort of draw and the straw hats fly up
to Sky Island anyways here they defeat
the lightning fruit user and all a lot
easier because of Luffy's rubber body
and also because of their experience
with hockey and here again Luffy could
maybe even try to recruit analy to his
crew but I would imagine that annel
would probably decline this and still
head for the moon and at this point
Luffy's bounty is significantly higher
than it was during the original story no
surprise here because Luffy's obsession
with strength would likely mean that he
doesn't worry about causing destruction
so similarly to his rival used as kit
his Bounty would rise even higher and
even faster and after this the straw
hats now face one of their toughest
challenges yet the Admiral aokiji the
chili fruit user has come to reclaim
Robin and he is simply way too powerful
for the crew to take on and this leads
to an interesting dilemma since this
version of Luffy has much less of a bond
with his crewmates it is possible that
he could simply abandon Robin however
much like he welcomed Nami back in this
case he surprisingly decides to
challenge the Admiral one-on-one for
Robin's freedom and Luffy wouldn't be
quite as easily overwhelmed as he was
back in chapter 321. this version of
Luffy is stronger and knows hockey but
of course he would most likely still
fairly quickly lose and have to be saved
by the crew's doctor random joke but
this takes us to water 7 where the crew
still needs a new ship after their crazy
descent from skypeia this Arc plays out
similar to the original Luffy already
put his neck on the line for Robin when
he fought out kiji so he isn't going to
let the world government take her now as
well duh so the arc ends with Frankie
making them a new ship before he joins
the crew and as an added bonus Luffy is
much more interested in Frankie's
weapons and he demands more guns on the
new ship as well and now I'm bored of
their new ship the straw hats seek out
fights with other strong Pirates and
Marines on the grand line before
eventually reaching the zombie-infested
floating island Thriller bark here Luffy
Stomps the warlord gekkomoria and Brooke
joins the crew and since the crew as a
whole is much stronger here they're also
able to escape from the warlord Kuma
without too much trouble this time
however next is where it gets
interesting next is sabaoli where the
straw had suffer an even worse defeat
than they did in the original story now
in chapter 506 we meet this old man so
wasraeli who was the right hand of the
former pirate king Roger and Rayleigh
has actually been waiting for Luffy
since the time that Shanks told him
about a certain kid who resembled their
former Captain Roger and originally
Rayleigh helps the crew as they prepare
to enter the new world but in this
version things are going quite
differently both Ray daily and shangs
have heard of Luffy's cold-hearted
journey through the Grand line and they
now believe that Luffy is actually not
fit to wear the straw hats this leads to
Rayleigh to demand that Luffy changes
his ways or gives up the hat and Luffy
of course wouldn't pay him any attention
which would lead to a mind-blowing
confrontation between the two Rayleigh
challenges Luffy for the right to the
straw hat and Luffy of course still
being Luffy kind of has to accept here
and of course Rayleigh who was said to
be nearly as strong as the former pirate
king himself would destroy Luffy and
take the hat from Luffy's unconscious
heads well if you didn't have that on
your bingo card did you now this result
sends the story in many different ways
the first route we're going to explore
has Luffy's staying on sabaori where he
votes to take the straw head back from
Rayleigh however it is also at this time
that the world government announces that
Luffy's brother Ace is going to be
executed so Luffy and the crew had to
Marie lean forwards and just as much as
Luffy wants to free Ace he's equally
excited to fight all the crazy strong
Marines and Pirates Who are coming to
the war as well here the straw has
arrived at Marine Forge just as the
battle is on the way and while this
version of the straw hats are definitely
way stronger than they were in the
original story at this point they are
still no match for the combined might of
mihawk the Cyber parsifista and the
Marine Admirals and in this situation
let's be honest it is also very likely
that the emperor of the sea whitebeards
would not trust Luffy so instead of
really being allies here they'd probably
just get into each other's ways this
leads to Ace being executed as plans
meaning that Luffy feels even more
miserably than in the original story
perhaps a fitting lesson that the
pursuit of power will not always get you
what you want and after this assuming
that Luffy even survives he would most
likely still be devastated over the loss
of his brother and humiliated that he
was too weak to save him this could send
him into an even deeper spiral where he
becomes more desperate for power and
this mindset would probably set him on a
similar track to the last man that tried
to take over the world Roxy's back and
while we don't know much about this
pirate we do know that he was insanely
powerful and that he tried to kill the
world Nobles and I think that this
version of Luffy would take the same
path and meet the same end where he
would be killed in battle never having
regained the straw hats okay but now
let's back all the way up after Luffy's
defeat to Rayleigh because from here
option two and three follow mostly the
same Roots but with a few decisive
differences in the original story Luffy
punches this world Noble for trying to
enslave his mermaid friends well this
version of Luffy wouldn't necessarily
care about the slavery I think his
frustration after losing to Rayleigh
could very easily cause him to attack a
world novel anyway just like in the main
story this would summon them Marines the
Cyber passifista and the Admiral kizaru
to take out the straw hats and while
they might be able to survive the Posse
fista and even Kuma maybe who they
already escaped from on Thriller bark in
this version Rayleigh would clearly not
save them from kizo so Luffy would be
captured thrown into the underwater
prison and pull down and erased from the
story or not
remember this is also around the time
that Blackbeard breaks into imple down
to recruit strong criminals to his crew
so let's assume that Ace is still taken
to Marine for it Blackbeard overthrows
the prison and he takes the strongest
prisoners with him including I already
Luffy that's right ladies and gentlemen
evil Luffy and Blackbeard are now part
of the same crew for now so the black
bit Pirates traveled to marineford with
the goal of killing whitebeards and
taking his devil fruit however this is
where Luffy goes wild because at this
point Ace has already been executed
Luffy realizes that he failed to save
his brother because he was locked in
jail which causes him to lose his mind
he starts to fight anyone in his path
Admirals Whitebeard commanders Warlords
of the sea he would probably even awaken
his conquerors haki due to the immense
rage that he's in however this is when
Shang shows up to stop the war Shanks
demands that everyone stops fighting and
while the Marines and other Pirates
start pulling back Luffy refuses to quit
Shanks is also wearing Luffy Straw Hat
now and in a rush of Madness Luffy
challenges Shanks to a jewel for the
hands now consider how Shanks would be
feeling at this moment he's facing the
kid who he once and trusted with his
treasured straw hat and the faith of the
world the kid who he hoped would grow up
to become the next pirate king but now
standing before him is a twisted version
who has been driven mad by his lust for
power thanks being who he is initially
tries to talk Luffy out of fighting but
Luffy will not give up and eventually
Shanks a grease hoping that he can teach
Luffy a lesson and get him to change his
ways in a last desperate attempt however
if they do fight this version of Luffy
simply has no chance at all of defeating
Shanks whatsoever and it is here where
we can can split off into our final two
options for how this could go for
Luffy's future one way this could go is
that Shanks takes down Luffy but as
we've seen so often in the story Luffy
refuses to stay down and even if Shanks
begs him to stop Luffy won't quit he
keeps coming for Shanks and the redhead
Pirates and ultimately Shanks is left
with no other choice he has to kill the
enraged and maddened Luffy and as you
might ask why Shanks would kill Luffy or
if Shanks thinks that Luffy would be a
danger to the world similar to rockstein
it would make sense for him to put Luffy
down especially since he knows Luffy's
devil fruit which now takes us to a
third path and the one that we will be
exploring a little bit more fully
because it is honestly the most
interesting let's imagine that Luffy has
been knocked down by Shanks again and
again and shanks's blade rests on
Luffy's neck and finally the robber boy
breaks down into tears he lets out all
of his Stout up anger and frustration he
thinks back on his journey so far and
all the cold-hearted things that he has
done and he finally realizes that he has
lost his way after losing his brother in
battle he realizes that he cannot keep
living like this and he wants to care
about the people around him and regrets
not caring more about his crew after all
at his core it's still the same Luffy as
in our story just misguided by shanks's
word at the beginning and so seeing this
Shanks offers Luffy a choice come away
from a rainforge with him and learn how
to be a great captain or die and having
had this Epiphany Luffy now accepts his
former mentor's offer and after some
time spent with the red hat Pirates he
is now reunited with his crew and this
takes us to the time Skip and now
instead of spending the two years
training separately the crew spends this
time bonding and forming the real
relationship that they had in the
original story and after the time skip
the story would continue much as it had
in the original story only with a few of
the crew members missing and random Joe
you got it and Luffy and his crew
Advanced through the new world now with
Luffy's greatest power his ability to
inspire others with his joyfulness his
friendship and his selflessness which is
a lesson that he had to learn the hard
way this time because he tried to
overcome everything with strength and
power but ultimately fails in the end he
was not strong enough and he nearly lost
everything including his brother at
Marine forts but this leads to an even
more interesting question what if Luffy
had been strong enough to save ASAP
Marine Fort could he have saved his
brother if he had his current storyline
powers in other words what would have
happened if gear 5 Luffy was at Marine
Fort if you want to find out check out
the video right here and Shanks for
watching